all right so and or episode 9 is out
right now and what a mic drop of a
finish that was but no worries in this
video we're going to be discussing that
ending some of the Easter eggs you might
have missed are theories for next
episode along with our reaction and
review of this episode I don't want to
waste any time so everybody on program
now if you enjoy this video then listen
up and hit that like button as it helps
the channel and also don't forget to
subscribe for reviews Recaps and other
videos like this every week with that
out of the way a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into Andor
episode nine so let's keep our mouths
shot keep our heads down
until we know what's going on
okay so if you're just coming out of
episode nine let's talk about that
ending scene and what it means as a
potential ripple effect into episode 10.
towards the end of their shift the team
has to keep Olaf standing because he's
suffering from what appears to be
exhaustion however things get worse
during the shift change resulting in
Olaf collapsing with Andor and Kino Loy
staying behind until the Medtech can
examine him ooloff only having 40 shifts
left Loy softly informs the Medtech of
this insisting on giving him just
anything to help keep him up however the
med tech cannot because ooloff has had a
massive stroke there's nothing he can do
the Medtech continues by saying Olaf is
one of the lucky ones that he will pass
peacefully unlike everyone else in the
prison another week like this then
you'll be begging for what he's getting
what do you mean the Medtech injects
ooloff allowing him to pass but the
previous comments from the Medtech have
awoken something in both Loy and Andor
questioning if he knows exactly what
happened on level 2 and if the rumor
about something bad happening down there
is in fact true it's revealed that
someone made a mistake a man was
released on level 4 and then wound up on
level 2 the next day Ward got out and
the overseers railed everyone on the
floor I mean I mean they they gave them
the Shocker no no everyone uh on the
floor uh died that yeah no one in the
entire prison is getting out as Andor
presses Loy about how many guards are on
each floor once again with him finally
giving in saying never more than 12.
basically they are Kino and or everyone
that has been counting down their
sentences are going nowhere not only are
the sentences completely made up the
numbers don't matter which is something
melshi had a feeling was happy happening
in episode 8. don't have a look at the
number double triple it doesn't matter
hey you're into they don't want you
anymore you're not get straight with
that Mouse right thanks again I know
streaming those days are over but even
if someone is quote released they will
just be swapped out into another floor
with another made-up sentence to
continue this cycle again and again
until whatever it is they are building
which I'm still saying are pieces to the
Death Star is complete these prisoners
mean nothing to the Empire the
placements in their day shifts don't
mean anything they are workhorses and
Kino finally realizes this leaning into
andor's plans for an escape informing
them of his guard knowledge it's only a
matter of time before The Secret Gets
Out to more and more floors and it was
hinted that they had been frying larger
groups of prisoners in this episode by
the couple of power flickers Floor 2
obviously being the main example so it's
really a race against the clock for
Andor Kino and everyone else now before
we get into our theories on what the
next episode holds like it's gonna be a
huge prison break with like jar jar
blasting them out
boom boom let's talk about some of the
episodes Easter eggs in Jared's Easter
eggs
[Music]
Miro mentions some of her colleagues
take a quick and easy approach like
Blevins conflicting reports that Khan
later disapproved of whereas she is more
thorough a more nuanced view she tries
but we know this is poor logic because
of Yoda's teachings in Empire Strikes
Back
or do not
there is no try melshi who we mentioned
earlier is played by Duncan Powell and
is not only part of andor's Table 5 crew
but seemingly shows up in Rogue one
breaking out jyn urso and also fighting
on scarif meaning that Andor recruits
him after this assumed prison break or
escape the prison guard's boots look
similar to the prison boots from
Face-Off instead of magnetizing them to
the floor they prevent shocking against
the tungstoid floor also fun fact the
Face-Off boots were actually repurposed
Goomba boots from the 1993 Super Mario
Bros movie so uh the more you know the
prison uniforms with the white and
orange coloring look similar to prison
uniforms used in real life but more
importantly they are similar Styles as
those from Star Wars Rebels and the
factory labor workers worn on Lothian in
a season 3 episode 10. Andy Circus plays
Kino Lloyd the man in charge of level
5's day shift however circus also
performed motion capture and Voice work
for snoke in the sequel trilogy but we
all know his time in that role was
cut short the scenes of Bix being
interrogated by Dr Gorst involve a
similar looking headset that was worn by
lobot in Empire Strikes Back the
official name is an aj6 cyborg construct
essentially an imperial technology
headset designed to increase
productivity in low level workers but on
Bix it's used as torture Dr Gorst uses
death screams of dysonite dizzinite
Dizon night children the Empire had
eradicated to torture Bix this form of
quote enhanced interrogation has
actually been used by the CIA constantly
blaring crying children man it's like my
showing of Black Adam hey hey you shut
that baby up the brilliant transition of
Bix screaming to the drill in the prison
is a perfect symbol of the Empire
drilling down for information but from
the entirely wrong sources this quote
interviewing scene with 6 also adds to
the ever-growing list of differing
methods of interrogation in the Star
Wars Galaxy being similar to that of the
boar gullet used by sagarera in Rogue
one the interrogation Droid or Ito
interrogator used in A New Hope and the
scan grid used on Han in Empire Strikes
Back the Imperial Guard mentions that
he'd like to hang salmon [ __ ] to show
the people of pharynx who is actually in
charge here and a similar thing happened
to andor's Father Clem as hinted at by
Luth and back in episode 3 and also
shown in the flashbacks of episode 7.
Cassian removing the panel using a tiny
tool to cut through the power to escape
is like one of the handful of iconic
prison escape movies out there most
notably Shawshank Redemption because of
the tiny rock hammer Andy Dufresne uses
mon mothma mentions the public order
resentencing directive or poured the law
that the prisoners ask about in you know
last week's episode is the next step in
total controlled by the Empire but also
used as a way to speed up the production
of the Death Star because it's mentioned
that they are behind schedule in later
films and or even mentions that
prisoners are way cheaper than droids
and easier to replace mothma mentions
the Senate as a temple before palpatina
took control the Jedi Temple and Senate
had very similar viewpoints both church
and state were connected at this time
rather than what we see here Vel
mentions that she was traveling for the
last six months which was actually her
time on the aldani job mothma has no
clue that Vel her cousin from what we
learn here was one of them in the heist
job therefore creating another
connection to the Rebellion than just
Lutheran this talk between Andor and
Kino about how The Empire is essentially
fat dumb incompetent has some of the
same kind of Beats as andor's first
conversation with Lutheran almost as
Andor himself is a spark of the
Rebellion passing his rebellious Spirit
on without him really even knowing it
Miriam makes the connection to and or
being involved with aldani and pharynx
because a witness said that they saw a
clean shaven which relates back to his
Imperial mugshot hologram from earlier
ironically him shaving which in any
other situation would hide his identity
instead made it much clearer Karn is
having a delicious breakfast of blue
milk and some sort of cereal at first
thought they could be greedos raisin
hand or even Carn flakes but uh yeah
it's just the blue and purple pieces
from the 2020 limited edition trolls
World Tour tricks cereal silly rabbit
tricks are for Carnes the conversation
between Karn and Miro outside of the ISB
headquarters seems like a fun little oh
I have such a crush on you type meeting
but instead you can feel the Sith
culture seeds underneath the Empire with
Karn craving power wanting what Miro has
while Miro selfishly shrugs him off Miro
is made aware that a rebel in possession
of an elite legal Imperial masking unit
is being held on a destroyer off of
steer guard stearguard being the same
Naval Yard and or store the Imperial
star path unit from earlier in this
series The chandrillian financer
mentioned to help mothma is Davos Colton
which is a character I'm sure mothma
grew up with or is aware of but I think
it's more a play on words here because
Davos is located in Switzerland and they
are dealing with Bankers here so
basically a Swiss Banker is what they
are kind of alluding to and Swiss bank
accounts stereotypically allow for high
levels of privacy this is what mothma
needs or I made the most outlandish
connection and just wasted your time
ah
your support is well seen Anto Krieger
was mentioned by sagarera in last week's
episode and the Empire has one of his
crew members in custody Guerrera
mentioned that Krieger was slow and
stupid which explains why the Empire is
now blowing up his spot further mentions
of Catherine which is where Andor
collects the Intel at the beginning of
Rogue one potentially being actually one
of Krieger's men there's also
conversation of killing the pilot
forging official documents to say that
it was all an accident and then using
him as bait which is all too real way of
showing how the corruption amongst the
Empire is a thing and also mirrors that
of real life authorities and the med
tech is featured in a different white
and teal outfit teal is often a color
associated with revitalizing and
rejuvenating hence a medical
professional but also represents open
communication and Clarity of thought
which feels like him informing Andor and
Kino of the incident on level 2 and Kino
ending the episode with a clear mind and
giving up the guard numbers and that has
been Jared's Easter eggs
[Music]
now as for where episode 10 goes It's
gotta be the prison break right word is
slowly spreading about what happened on
level 2 and none of the prisoners are
actually able to leave the facility this
is all ramping up in a similar way that
the heist did on aldani even in this
episode around like the 13 minute Mark
and or Mudders that the platform and the
elevator don't have shock floors because
the guards are not wearing their boots
while the new guy on the floor doesn't
appear to be shocked by hitting the
railing they're gonna stop the elevator
halfway and climb out of this mess maybe
also tying in with like the wires or
whatever the Andor was trying to cut
into earlier in this episode potentially
cutting the power to the lift Andor is
the spark to get these people on board
with the Rebellion we already know that
melshi winds up with him in Rogue one
while realizing the Empire are straight
up pieces of bantha Duty just a theory
but if they get out of this prison all
need to see a half-built Death Star I
will not be surprised as for Miro and
mothma I have a feeling that this raid
at spellhouse will be cut short before
any progress can be made with a captured
Krieger giving up Lutheran's name as
axis which in turn shakes up mothma's
plans and then she has to move forward
with whatever Arrangement this Davos
Colden has in mind let me know what sort
of craziness you think is going to go
down in these next couple weeks as for
Andor this series from weekend to week
out has exceeded my expectations like
blown them away it's a slow burn of
these interconnected stories almost
entirely being new characters we have
never had time with before and then
fleshing out their character but not
only that the worlds and ideologies that
they live in surprisingly some of them
on the completely opposite sides of the
spectrum but having similar thoughts I
love how Tony Gilroy has tuned this into
like a blade runner-esque clean and
crisp sci-fi dystopian story with the
past two episodes being in this prison
The Establishment leading to escalated
events and then the overwhelming tension
of watching a plan unravel with some
unexpected hiccups along the way that is
exactly what I'm hoping for for this
next episode a grandiose prison escape
with a last second pull the rug from
underneath one of the pivotal characters
but obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on episode 9 of Andor and if
you think this is going to lead into a
huge prison break with a lot of them
joining the rebellion and I'll let you
know we're currently running a
competition right now giving away three
copies of tap gun Maverick on the 15th
of November and all you gotta do all you
gotta do for a chance to win this is
like this video make sure to subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
Down Below on what you're digging about
and or right now we picked the comments
at random at the end of the month and
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that is
you message Paul on Twitter at
heavyspoilers if if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos whether it be
our John Carpenters the thing breakdown
or our Constant House of dragon videos
and enjoy with that out of the way
thanks for the constant support I've
been Jared and I have to get back on
program I'll see in the next one take
care and peace